um Lord Winston thank you for coming on
our show today now the NHS is never out
of the headlines at the moment and the
thing I wanted to start off asking you
is how big a crisis do we find ourselves
in today when it comes to our Health
Service
I think it's a very real very serious
crisis I don't think we've certainly
I qualified medicine in 19
right not even
64 and there's never been a crisis like
that since
um and I think it's a bit like a battle
you know when you start to lose control
of the battle that's when it gets really
bad and what's happened now of course is
the government's actually lost control
what do you mean when you say they've
lost control
well when you have ambulances clearly
outside hospitals when you've got people
dying unnecessarily unfortunately when
you see people with heart attacks and
with cancer not being treated on time I
mean that is actually losing control of
healthcare so when ke Stormer says he
thinks it's the worst crisis in the
nhs's history he's not making a
political point you don't think you
think that that is the truth I'm sure
and you know I I know I sit on the labor
benches in the House of Lords but you
know really I see myself really as more
of a cross-benching mind and but I mean
kirst armor is absolutely right he's
completely trustworthy and I don't have
any doubt that really what he's saying
is really from the heart and and Lord
Winston the government you know I talk
to ministers about this and to number 10
about what's going on they often talk
about the legacy of covid that that has
compounded the problems that's created
these huge waiting lists people not
going in uh to see doctors during those
two years where the pandemic really
absorbed the whole attention not just of
the country but the Health Service
obviously that there is some truth in
that isn't it it's not it's not entirely
I would put it in a different way I
would say that the government have been
incredibly lucky with kovid because
actually in fact it delayed it this in
fact gave them a perfect excuse not to
do things and they've been sitting
complacency while this has been going on
so covert has directed everything and
actually so you this is this crisis was
inevitable without covered there's no
question about that it was it was
absolutely clear if you look at the
graphs of everything going on they're
going off almost in a linear fashion
waiting lists ambulance problems people
dying people not getting diagnoses right
the way through for years before covered
so this has been a long-term problem and
it's been going on at least for 10 12
years probably longer and it's been
clear that there has been massive
underfunding of the house Health Service
so Lord with just to be clear your view
is that covert has given the government
cover to blaze underlying problems no
question and in fact don't forget they
were warned about coven we had the
select committee I sit on in the House
of Lords at Science and Technology had
repeatedly pointed out there was bound
to be a pandemic when kissed armor then
says
I don't want to talk about funding that
is dishonest isn't it because isn't that
partly what a political leader should
talk about and it was disingenuous to
say it's all about reform it doesn't
need more money I'm not prepared to say
that Kirsten is dishonest if he says I'm
not going to talk about the funding it
may be because his views on the funding
are currently fluid right and in fact I
think that actually we should have that
fluid View and I think that's reasonable
and I think in fact if we ever get round
to having a
cross party agreement it's not going to
come very easily because neither side is
going to want to sit down like this
because actually whoever does this could
lose a huge number of votes but actually
we have to start thinking not
politically but actually in terms of
what really is needed and that's a very
big difference sort of thinking the
unthinkable yes look we know from the
first world war if you fight a battle
politically you lose it and that's what
the politicians did on both sides large
numbers of lives are lost on the German
and the English side because the
politicians were trying to direct the
war and actually this is the same sort
of thing we've got to really look about
what is really needed in terms of
managing a proper Healthcare System do
you personally think that the NHS does
need
more resource and more funding yes
people are scared about talking about
this aren't they because they're wary
that reform is code for diluting the
principle of the NHS being free for all
this is a political issue isn't it in
that sense it's a issue we should deal
with with some humility isn't it that's
really what we need to do and actually
recognize that nobody has a perfect
answer but actually one thing we could
certainly do is to look at systems which
are better than our NHS you know for
years we have boasted the NHS is the
best best healthcare system in the world
doctors will tell you that it's not the
doctors who go outside this country and
many of them do I've worked in the
United States I've worked in Europe I've
had jobs in Belgium for example I've
been in the front line in other
countries and actually there are many
examples across Europe in particular but
also elsewhere where in fact there is
better care than we're giving and we
have to understand ourselves what have
we done that could have been done what
do we do now to try and do that it means
a change in the way that we do things it
doesn't mean to say that we don't want
to see health care for everybody of
course we do that is perfect a
reasonable proper entitlement and a good
democracy but it needs to be done
fearlessly and it's going to have to be
very difficult to do I don't I don't
doubt that Lord Winston I actually
interviewed sadri Javid the former
Health secretary at the end of last year
and we touched upon this and he said
we need to talk about the funding of the
NHS and then I said well what particular
model do you like France do you like
Germany what are you looking at and he
didn't want to discuss that and he
basically said that no one can talk
about this because they are shouted down
I think you're saying that that needs to
end but do you accept that that probably
cannot happen until after a general
election you know what that's what
happened to me in the year 2000 when I
was shuttered down by Aleister Campbell
and Tony Blair came back on the phone
and said you know you're quite right
we're going to increase the funding
and he did massively and of course Blair
had a very large majority May well be
that the next government will have a
very large majority is this a call to
care start with that in a way to kind of
show something yes I would I would love
to talk to care because I I have a huge
regard for him now at the moment it's
very clear that this government is burnt
out
so there's every reason why we should be
thinking about what we would do if we
did have a massive majority and start to
attract us with that you talked about
other assists other countries use hybrid
systems of Public Funding and private
insurance is that what you think the UK
needs well I'll tell you what you know
had we done what I wanted
um when the labor government was in
to really bring Private Practice into
the NHS hospital so that we had not
private clinics in Holly Street but
private clinics actually in our main
Central hospitals and really where
Consultants no longer had to drive out
to a private Clinic that would go next
door and you wouldn't have a
differential treatment because they
wouldn't treat patients differently but
you there are still hospitals where that
happens for example but on the whole it
doesn't really happen very much and a
huge amount of income has been lost as a
resulting consequence because of a Dogma
associated with private practice just in
terms of other other areas of reform
because they were talking about
reorganization kirst armor has suggested
more self referral now you are practic
you know you were a practitioner you're
an expert do you think that's a good
idea that that the people self-refer is
that just time wasting because it's
unwise for unwise referrals I think it's
something I said people with
self-bleeding internal bleeding could
well I mean don't you need to go to a e
if you've got into well I think it's
difficult to understand quite what he
meant but I mean if you meant if you
meant that you know just being aware of
symptoms earlier and then for doing
something about it yeah I would agree
with that if you mean self-fulfill in
terms of how most doctors seem to
perceive it and you saw them on the news
they were horrified
um I'm not clear quite what he had in
mind there to be fair and I think that's
quite important too but we should have
more Health Care information available
and I think we do need a more robust
Primary Care system and at the moment
that's not adequate either so for
example we have very good General
Practitioners but more and more people
as soon as they get to a reasonable age
really Eve so the the loss of retention
of workers in the Health Service is
scandalous and it's because of the very
poor circumstances and the fact that
they're not actually having any not
being listened to it well actually took
it and I was I might as well bring it
this up now I mean now you've brought it
up uh just quickly I I don't want to
make this into a news interview but
narcissist pay doctor's pay ambulance
workers pay does the government need to
move on this yes you think they do
of course we're not we're not paying
nearly enough
and is that affecting retention I mean
what well I'm out the argument about you
know if a nurse can walk out of a prime
an HS Hospital one day and walk into a
private Clinic the next day with an
increase not only a not only increased
salary or just better working conditions
being treated in a more human way I mean
but having having working hours which
are which are acceptable and being able
to work part-time perhaps whatever it
might mean I mean we've not been that
flexible we've been better at that but
if you talk to if you talk to well you
saw the nurses on the news yesterday it
makes you cry to see them crying to see
them shouting and screaming in that sort
of way that kind of angst that is not
usually shown by nurses and doctors feel
that just as much but they probably
don't say it quite so loudly
I I think there's been a great deal that
could be done with pay certainly the
pension reform is really urgently needed
that's clearly enough iniquitous but
there are other things that could be
done as well yeah I think we have to pay
people what their value what their value
to society is and we value the NHS and
we value the NHS greatly that means that
we have to actually consider what is
really worth to us and and Lord Winston
labor this week also revealed figures
showing that 37 000 people with
conditions like a tax or heart attacks
or Strokes a category two callers it's
described waited more than three and a
half hours for an ambulance in December
I mean what happens if you know they
what happens I mean you you I don't know
but if you have to wait an um an hour
for an ambulance and you've got a
suspected stroke or heart attack what
happens to that person well you lose
part of your brain which dies possibly
and of course you then have irreparable
damage so you are a much bigger cost of
the Health Service the rest of your life
which may be diminished of course
so when you see those ambulance Figures
it's not saving money it's actually
costing money it's actually costing
money to keep stroke people waiting it's
nobody's ever said that before but it's
obviously true
well so you what would your just to
finish off and thank you for for
spending so much time talking to me but
what's your message then to political
leaders right now well I would like to
just hear honestly I think I'd like to
see honesty at the dispatch box and when
they're asked questions we're not
getting that enough I think we all have
to be honest because nobody has the
answers and I think we really need a
degree of humility we can't just keep on
boasting about Healthcare there are
pockets of really fabulous stuff going
on you know the moment I'm under under
the under the care of moorfield Hospital
seeing two different Consultants as an
NHS patient and they're brilliant you
know you think this is world-class stuff
it is but the support for them because
of you know the you know the paperwork
and so on is really not adequate and you
feel it's so it's so shocking that
really we have these Pockets but the
health service is not delivering what it
could do
and that needs really careful and
reorganization and the use of better
data to better management and you would
and as a private citizen a person that's
worked in the NHS that's given so much
to this country in terms of innovative
Health Care you would pay more tax for a
better NHS of course no question
okay Lord Winston thank you so much it
was a real pleasure and honor to meet
you so thank you so much for coming on
the show thank you thank you